risikogebiet spanien die bundesregierung
reagiert auf die stark gestiegenen
infektionszahlen im land mit ausnahme
der kanaren gilt für reiserückkehrer
jetzt testpflicht freiheit für
demonstranten die regierung in belarus
lässt hunderte inhaftierte wieder frei
trotzdem protestieren die menschen
weiter gegen präsident lukaschenko die
eu bringt sanktionen auf den weg und
entscheidungen in der champions league
rb leipzig jubelt nach dem sieg gegen
atletico madrid
heute abend trifft bayern münchen auf
den fc barcelona
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sieber und in allen an diesem
hochsommer freitag geben sie uns 20
minuten wir geben ihnen den überblick
über die nachrichtenlage und rudi hat
nachher den sport im blick hallo schön
guten amt die lage für urlauber in
diesem sommer wird immer verzwickter und
komplizierter jetzt hat die
bundesregierung ganz spanien zum
risikogebiet erklärt mit ausnahme der
kanarischen inseln
das heißt wer dort war muss danach in
quarantäne bis sie oder er einen
negativen test vorweisen kann
das kommt überraschend für viele
urlauber das ist verheerend für die
reisebranche
schauen wir auf die spanischen zahlen
nach der ersten welle im frühjahr hatte
sich die lage eigentlich entspannt aber
jetzt sieht es so aus als sei eine
zweite welle angekommen
insgesamt sind 342 1813 menschen mit
corona infiziert zum neuen risikogebiet
gehört auch die beliebte urlaubsinsel
mallorca sogar eine reisewarnung droht
jetzt annafest berichtet mallorca bank
zwei tagen der kritische grenzwert von
50 neuinfektionen pro 100.000 einwohner
ist seit dienstag überschritten
jetzt ist die entscheidung aus
deutschland dar seit heute nachmittag
gelten die balearen als risikogebiet das
betrifft uns wirtschaftlich schon sehr
hier können viele deutsche hin hat man
weniger wirtschaft gut wäre eine balance
zwischen beiden schon jetzt ist mallorca
schwer wirtschaftlich getroffen die
folgen einer reisewarnung könnten
verheerend sein
das wäre eine katastrophe hier vor uns
weil dann wäre das summe vorbei
dabei fühlen sich die deutschen
touristen auf ihrer lieblingsinsel noch
ganz wohl
wenn ich die strände sie ja an ostsee
und nordsee sage ich mal würde ich sagen
dass es dort nicht so sicher wie hier
es ist eine gefühlte sicherheit denn das
corona virus ist in spanien wieder
zurück in den letzten zwei wochen gab es
42.000 neue fälle
wir haben in den letzten wochen einen
starken anstieg der fallzahlen
beobachtet deswegen mussten wir uns
beraten und einstimmig maßnahmen
ergreifen
verena die zu den maßnahmen gehört auch
ein rauchverbot im freien mit raucher
patrouille im einsatz
sie müssen ihren mund mehr bedecken na
klasse dann kann ich den rauch ja noch
besser genießen sie verbieten uns alles
rauchen man muss distanz halten
du kannst deine freunde nicht treffen es
wird immer schlimmer für die deutschen
touristen beginnt jetzt das nachdenken
urlaub in spanien wird kompliziert
spanien rückkehrer müssen jetzt also zum
test gehen wir zur peter wagner am
frankfurter flughafen haben peter was
heißt denn das jetzt für deutschlands
flughäfen und die reiseveranstalter ganz
konkret ja das ist erstmal ein schlag
ins kontor für spanien für die ganze
branche denn spanien ist er mit abstand
das beliebteste auslandsziele deutschen
letztes jahr also vor corona waren neun
millionen deutsche in spanien 5,3
millionen allein auf den inseln im
mittelmeer und das ganz spanien jetzt
mit wenigen ausnahmen als risikogebiet
gilt das für manche regionen sogar die
reisewarnung gilt das wirft also alle
zarten hoffnungen auf erholungen in der
branche auch in der luftfahrt deutlich
zurück und das ist wirklich eine
eiskalte dusche die sich so jetzt gar
keiner gewünscht hat der wagen war das
frankfurter flughafen herzlichen dank
und auch in frankreich wächst die sorge
über immer mehr corona infektionen
die regierung hat jetzt reagiert und
paris und marseille zu risikozonen
erklärt britische urlauber die aus
frankreich zurückkommen nach
großbritannien müssen für zwei wochen in
quarantäne
das gilt schon ab morgen früh jetzt
versuchen viele touristen das land davor
noch schnell zu verlassen
derzeit halten sich in frankreich
hunderttausende britische urlauber auf
in deutschland ist die zahl der
neuinfektionen weiter gestiegen das
robert koch institut meldet 1449
neuinfektionen der trend nach oben zeigt
sich auch im durchschnitt der letzten
sieben tage danach haben sich pro tag
1000 30 menschen neu angesteckt gestern
lag der schnitt bei 960
nach der korona test panne in bayern ist
noch immer nicht klar ob alle fast 1000
infizierten reiserückkehrer über ihre
ansteckung informiert wurden
die landesregierung hatte am mittwoch
eingeräumt dass insgesamt 44.000
getestete noch auf ihre ergebnisse
warteten damit infizierte urlauber
möglichst schnell erkannt werden gibt es
in immer mehr bundesländern corona
teststationen den grenznähe wie hier
seit heute an autobahnen in sachsen seit
beginn der korona pandemie hat das virus
in deutschland mindestens 220.000
menschen infiziert nachgewiesen durch
einen positiven test klar ist aber auch
dass es eine dunkelziffer gibt also
nicht erkannte infektionen
aber wie groß ist diese dunkelziffer
eigentlich wohl niedriger als viele
meinen zeigt eine neue studie des
robert-koch-instituts selbst in einem
ehemaligen hotspot wie kupferzell in
baden württemberg lassen sich nur bei
7,7 prozent der bürger antikörper
nachweisen
laut lka wäre das zu wenig um eine
zweite infektionswelle zu verhindern und
zu dieser antikörper studie des
robert-koch-instituts haben wir weitere
informationen und hintergründe für sie
zusammengestellt alles nachzulesen
online in der zdf- heute- app so viel zu
diesem thema
dann sollten wir jetzt in der sendung
auf die lage in belarus gucken gerade
mal zwei flugstunden von uns entfernt
ein europäisches land die eu
außenminister beraten ob es sanktionen
gegen die belarussische führung geben
soll
staatschef alexander lukaschenko lässt
mittlerweile demonstranten wieder frei
die festgenommen worden waren weil sie
lukaschenkos wiederwahl für manipuliert
halten die proteste sind damit aber
nicht beendet im gegenteil seit der
präsidentenwahl am letzten sonntag
eskaliert die gewalt in belarus in minsk
und vielen anderen städten gehen die
menschen auf die straße
die opposition spricht von massivem
wahlbetrug immer wieder in den letzten
tagen gehen sicherheitskräfte brutal
gegen demonstranten vor
mit gummigeschossen schlagstöcken und
blendgranaten es gab nach offiziellen
angaben fast 7000 festnahmen hunderte
verletzte und zwei tote und wie geht es
weiter
für begann
geh weg rufen die mitarbeiter des
staatseigenen chemiewerks im westen von
belarus traktorenbauer u bahn personal
immer mehr belegschaften schließen sich
den rufen nach einem freien wähler ruß
an
seit tagen war nichts von alexander
lukaschenko zu sehen heute wagt er den
spagat warnt vor den wirtschaftlichen
folgen der streiks um sie gleichzeitig
kleinzureden
in einigen betrieben haben wohl so 20
leute ihre meinung gesagt und aufgehört
zu arbeiten
ihre bosse haben ihnen gesagt okay geht
es gibt genug die bleiben wollen
die bekommen dann euren lohnen mehrere
tausend bei den protesten festgenommene
ließ das regime heute überraschend frei
vor den gefängnissen verarzten
freiwillige ihre wunden die von
misshandlungen und polizeigewalt zeugen
spezialkräfte haben mit gummikugeln auf
mich geschossen
auch ins bein und in die brust auf den
rücken haben sie ein geknüppelt wieso
hat mir niemand erklärt aus dem exil
macht die selbsterklärte wahlsiegerin
ihren anhängern mut es mit lahti
hanowski anrufe zu neuen friedlichen
protesten auf verurteilt das blutbad das
der machthaber anrichte deutliche worte
findet auch außenminister maß wir
verfolgen die lage dort sehr aufmerksam
all das was dort geschehen ist in den
letzten tagen und wochen ist völlig
inakzeptabel und bedarf einer klaren
antwort der europäischen union
die antwort der belarussen auf den druck
des regimes ist deutlich blumen und
balance vor dem parlament die
sicherheitskräfte reagieren zum ersten
mal seit tagen zurückhaltend bisher
bringen unsere korrespondenten mit rein
in moskau und in brüssel und bevor wir
auf europas reaktion gucken zunächst
nach moskau christiansen und haben
christian erst viele festnahmen jetzt
wieder freilassungen haben die proteste
den staatschef gar zum einlenken bewegt
oder was steckt dahinter
nein das glaube ich nicht es war ein
zugeständnis aber liegt vielleicht auch
einfach daran dass die haftanstalten
sehr überfüllt waren
bis zu diesem zeitpunkt und es ist ja
damit auch überhaupt nicht gesagt ob in
den nächsten tagen nicht wieder tausende
menschen festgenommen werden
präsident lukaschenko zeigt sich
überhaupt nicht dialogbereit und geht
überhaupt nicht auf die demonstranten zu
bezeichnet sie als arbeitslose als
bekiffte als scharfen macht sich eher
über sie lustig und deswegen ist nicht
damit zu rechnen dass die jetzt in
nächster zeit irgendwie ins gespräch
kommen sogar schenkel sagt weiter ich
bin präsident ich will das mit aller
macht bleiben zur not auch mit hilfe des
militärs
und wie sehen das die demonstranten
werden die diese demonstration jetzt
weitergehen den nächsten tagen ja unser
team in minsk ad hoc mit vielen menschen
gesprochen die zeigen sich natürlich
schockiert über diese gewalt und sagen
wir verstehen gar nicht was hier los ist
wir sind doch eigentlich friedliche
menschen und im moment sieht so aus als
würden trotzdem weiter viele auf die
straße gehen wollen was wochenende sind
weitere aktionen und demonstrationen
geplant auch die beerdigung eines
getöteten demonstranten und die
demonstranten wollen den druck auf das
lukaschenko system weiter hoch halten
und dann weiter nach brüssel
anne gellinek das passiert das nur so
mal festhalten in einem europäischen
staat wie nachdrücklich wird denn die
antwort der eu aussehen
der druck auf die eu außenminister ist
in den letzten tagen enorm gestiegen und
das hat offenbar auch dazu beigetragen
dass sich die eu beim thema belarus
jetzt doch noch einmal zusammengerauft
hat beschlossen ist noch nichts aber
alle 27 eu außenminister auch der
ungarische waren sich heute einig dass
man in richtung sanktionen gehen will
dass man eine liste beschließen will
auf der gezielt die person sich
wiederfinden sollen die verantwortlich
sind für die wahlfälschung in belarus
und für die misshandlungen von
demonstranten
diese personen sollen künftig nicht mehr
in die
die eu einreisen dürfen und ihre
auslandskonten so vorhanden werden
eingefroren des weiteren haben die
eu-außenminister einen form beschlossen
aus dem sie die weißrussische opposition
und die zivilgesellschaft unterstützen
wollen das sind natürlich zwei maßnahmen
die lukaschenko jetzt nicht zum zittern
bringen werden aber es ist doch eine
geste europäischer solidarität für die
demonstranten in belarus
vielen dank für diese information anne
und christian aus dem nahen osten
nachrichten die manche für historisch
halten dass israel und die vereinigten
arabischen emirate erstmals
zusammenrücken und botschafter
austauschen wollen wird fast überall
begrüßt von einem zukunftsweisenden
schritt spricht die bundesregierung
anders sehen das die türkei und iran sie
werfen den emiraten vor die interessen
der palästinenser zu verraten
julia fischers bericht beginnt in israel
zur feier des tages trägt tel aviv die
farben der vereinigten arabischen
emirate ein symbol für frieden zwischen
den ländern freundschaft zwischen den
staaten
das ist so aufregend und ein großer
moment für uns alle
alle sehen das nicht so in jerusalem
zeigen palästinenser nach dem
freitagsgebet ihre wut wut darüber dass
die annexion pläne zum westjordanland
immer noch nicht vom tisch sind während
abu dhabis kronprinz war twittert es
gebe eine einigung die die annexion
palästinensischer gebiete stopp sagt
israels premier netanjahu das gegenteil
an seinem plan werde sich grundsätzlich
nichts ändern
iran spricht von einem dolchstoß das
türkische außenamt von verrat an den
palästinensern
und die sehen das auch so wir
akzeptieren das überhaupt nicht es ist
unser land hier wir haben mit diesem
abkommen nichts zu tun das ist eine
schande dass es kein abkommen für die
bevölkerung es geht hier nur um
wirtschaftliche interessen und wohl
nicht nur um die netanjahu steht unter
druck da sind korruptionsvorwürfe und
sind in der umfragewerte spannend weil
das natürlich ein riesiger zugewinn ist
für die politik
netanjahus innenpolitisch also er steht
nämlich in der kritik seit längerer zeit
und es werden stimmen laut dass die
regierung sich jemand all auf die vierte
auf die vierte wahl vorbereitet ein
erfolg für netanjahu und ein erfolg für
die emirate die nun als drittes
arabisches land den diplomatischen weg
wählen und zu guter letzt soll es auch
ein erfolg für us-präsident trump werden
mitten im wahlkampf zu hause in den usa
genau da gehen wir jetzt hin für
us-präsident trump ist die briefwahl
eine einladung zum betrug und deshalb
ist die us-post plötzlich mittendrin im
wahlkampf aus einem einfachen grund sie
muss nämlich die briefwahl abwickeln bei
der präsidentenwahl im november
donald trump sagt ohne zusätzliches geld
schaffe die post ist gar nicht den
bürgern die wahlunterlagen zuzustellen
ob sie dieses geld bekommt darüber wird
jetzt heftig gestritten in washington
herr matti wissen berichtet mit ihrer
hilfe bekommen die menschen ihre
gehaltsschecks ihre medikamente bezahlen
ihre rechnungen die amerikaner sind
stolz auf ihre starts eigene post nun
muss sie in der pandemie zig-millionen
briefwahlstimmen transportieren so viel
wie nie zuvor
das ist toll doch die briefwahl so
behauptet der präsident
öffne dem wahlbetrug tür und tor
zugunsten der demokraten denen bietet
trump nun einen deal wenn sie seinem
corona hilfspaket zu stimmen bekommen
die post etwas mehr geld vielleicht aber
auch gar nichts weil sie einen deal
machen dann hat die post genug auch für
die briefwahl falls wir zustimmen das
heißt nicht dass wir zustimmen
zum chef der postbehörde hat trump luigi
einen freund und wahlkampf spender
gemacht dieser bestreitet nun im
radiointerview den eindruck dass er beim
postdienste entscheidungen auf befehl
des präsidenten oder der regierung fährt
trotzdem baut die scheu der zeit
personal ab und auch sortiermaschinen
die für die briefwahl wichtig wäre
typisch trump meint joe biden
er will keine wahl was diese regierung
unserem wahlsystem an tut unserem
heiligen recht zu wählen ist ein angriff
auf unsere verfassung
übrigens selbst gerade briefwahl in
florida beantragte und es gibt auch
keinerlei belege dass bei dieser form
der wahl im großen stil betrogen wird
solange amerika stolz die post die
stimmzettel pünktlich liefern kann und
wieder zurück nach deutschland jeder
lehrer soll einen dienst laptop bekommen
jeder schüler einen internetanschluss
für maximal zehn euro pro monat
darauf haben sich die bundeskanzlerin
die die bildungsminister und die
spd-chefin und die kultusminister
mehrere länder gestern abend verständigt
und vor allem schnelles internet für
alle schulen soll es geben endgültig
beschlossen werden soll das bald bei
einem treffen mit allen ländern und
jetzt eine traurige nachricht in eigener
sache der zdfkultur journalist volker
panzer ist tot panzer moderierte über
mehrere jahre die talksendung
nachtstudio erwarten sie keine witze von
mir ich kenne nämlich nur einen und der
geht so gutes segelwetter kein wind und
wieder hat keiner gelacht ich lasse es
lieber willkommen im nachtstudio der
gebürtige saarländer hatte im fernsehen
eine schillernde alternative erfunden
für querdenker jeglicher couleur volker
panzer wurde 73 jahre alt dann machen
wir ein stückchen der sendung und gehen
rüber zum sport bitte schön ruhig sehr
gerne der rb leipzig hat einen
grandiosen start in das finalturnier der
champions league hingelegt mit einer
taktischen meisterleistung in zauberte
die mannschaft von trainer julian
nagelsmann die stars von atletico madrid
mit 2 1 leipzig steht jetzt erstmals im
halbfinale der königsklasse
ausgelassen feiert die mannschaft in der
kabine den bisher größten erfolg der
vereinsgeschichte
die mannschaft von uns wird das andere
dort gesehen diese grenze wird viel von
außen reingetragen wir müssen unsere
grenze selber setzen und jungs haben
heute herausragend gearbeitet und
absolut verdient gewonnen
leipzig robusta frecher erfolgreicher
als atlético madrid ende dieses
wunderbaren spielzug daniel mit dem 10
den ausgleich per foulelfmeter erzielte
auf felix eins zu eins atletico der
zweimalige champions league finalist
scheint zurück aber das glück ist mit
den tüchtigen der schuss von tyler adams
zum 2 1 siegtreffer für leipzig
abgefälscht unhaltbar
leipzigs champions league traum geht
weiter am dienstag im halbfinale gegen
paris heute jetzt auch weiter mit
barcelona gegen bayern es ist auch das
aufeinandertreffen der beiden derzeit
besten stürmer der welt robert
lewandowski gegen lionel messi schon im
viertelfinale also ein spiel der
giganten
es wird ein duell der torjäger
lewandowski 13 treffer gegen messi diese
saison mit weniger spielen erst drei
treffer
ich denke jetzt nicht fc bayern münchen
gegen gegen messi sondern des fc bayern
münchen gegen gegen barcelona
doch allein das letzte tor gegen neapel
ist wieder ein besonderes fünf
gegenspieler schaffen es nicht den
inzwischen 33 jährigen am schuss zu
hindern du verteidigst als team gegen
messi wenn der erste den ball nicht
gewinnt dann ist der nächste da bayern
vertraut auf die starke form von robert
lewandowski zuletzt zweifacher
torschütze gegen chelsea das
torjäger-duell führt zum nächsten thema
denn tore verhindern sollen marc andré
ter stegen barcelona und manuel neuer
bayern noch ein duell der zwei deutschen
nationaltorhüter da ist was los und rad
profi emanuel buchmann zeigt sich bei
der dauphiné-rundfahrt weiterhin in
starker form
die dritte etappe über 157 kilometern
mit einer bergankunft in san martín de
belleville gewann der italiener da wir
die form olo nach langer solofahrt die
favoriten 33 sekunden zurück der
gesamtführende rock ridge zweiter
buchmann als vierter erneut im kreis der
besten und in der gesamtwertung nur 20
sekunden zurück das war's vom sport
regulieren tropisches wetter in
deutschland es ist heiß und es gibt
immer wieder unwetter schauen wir uns
die bilder an dazu das ist sachsen ihr
dort setzten gewitter mit starkregen
innerhalb kürzester zeit straßen und
keller unter wasser
in nordrhein-westfalen fielen gestern
abend an manchen orten mehr als 50 liter
regen pro quadratmeter und doch gab es
einige die sich über so viel wasser von
oben und von der seite
freunden und auch jetzt gibt es in den
meisten bundesländern lokale unwetter
warnungen und die gewitter allerdings
werden wir sobald nicht los zumindest
morgen noch donnert und schüttet es oft
details gleich von katja horneffer ich
empfehle ihnen das heute journal mit dem
kollegen claus kleber um 22 uhr
danke für heute gerne bis morgen aber
erst ihnen allen einen angenehmen
freitagabend
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren
schwül-warme gewittern luft liegt über
mitteleuropa und da bleibt sie auch noch
in den nächsten tagen liegen
so entwickeln sich gewitter häufig an
ort und stelle die nur ganz langsam
ziehen hier zwischen der nordseeküste
und dem bayerischen wald auch jetzt in
der nacht gibt es gewitter zwischen dem
erzgebirge und dem münsterland im
nordosten ist es dagegen zum teil klar
in der gewitter luft sinken die
temperaturen in ostfriesland bis 20 grad
und der klaren sternenhimmel in
nordfriesland geht es bis 13 grad runter
und morgen erwarten uns in bayern
höchsttemperaturen zwischen 23 und 25
grad sonst werden 26 bis 32 grad
erreicht und beim wetter ändert sich
wirklich wenig in schleswig holstein an
der ostseeküste da strahlt die sonne
sonst ist die luft sehr deutlich es gibt
immer wieder schauer und gewitter sie
können zum teil unwetterartig werden
weil sie nämlich nur so langsam ziehen
also mit kräftigen regenmengen verbunden
sein mit hagel und mit sturmböen
das gilt auch für süddeutschland von den
westlichen mittelgebirgen bis ins
berchtesgadener land im allgäu und
westlich davon richtung basel zeigt sich
dagegen häufig die sonne
der sonntag bringt weniger schauer und
gewitter und die neue woche startet
wieder gewittrig und wechselhaft schönen
abend noch